well if you thought your dating life was
bad wait till you check out sebastian
stan in fresh and thank god the role
didn't go to army hammer oh boy army
hammer 12 o'clock i don't know about you
guys but up here in canada this movie
about love and cannibalism released on
disney plus and it brings a whole new
meaning to the phrase family meal in
this video we'll be taking a look at
fresh it's hidden meaning and some of
the cool details you may have missed
along the way and stay tuned near the
end of the video where i'll be going
over some crazy theories on who steve's
wife really is but i'm getting a bit
ahead of myself so grab your favorite
snack and make sure to like and
subscribe because we're about to sink
our teeth into this fresh new horror
meet noah a 20 somethings woman who has
about as much luck finding love as i do
stephanie please take me back not only
does chad here not pay for the meal he's
rude to the waitress takes noah's
leftovers and her scarf is dipping into
the noodles not to mention he criticizes
her for not wearing a dress and when he
asks her out for a second date and she
declines he morphs into a total
douchebag good luck finding a guy you
stuck up [ __ ] that's noah's problem she
can't seem to find a nice guy and that's
one of the things i liked about the
first quarter of this movie instead of
telling us how bad her love life is we
actually get to see it then when she
eventually meets mr too good to be true
steve over here there's something to
compare it to and the two meet
ironically enough in the fresh vegetable
section of the local supermarket it's an
awkward but funny and kinda charming
meat cube where steve's able to get her
number she tells her friend molly that
she didn't believe people actually met
in real life anymore dating nowadays
seems to be relocated to superficial
online apps the one in this movie is
called puzzle piece since noah is
missing that one piece of her life that
she thinks will make her complete you
could also argue that this whole film is
an allegory for modern dating today one
in which we are simply pieces of meat to
be tossed aside steve and noah's first
date goes remarkably well he's a plastic
surgeon and the two have a lot in common
we have something in common i guess dead
parents that's actually an important
point as we'll find out later steve only
collects women with little to no friends
or family it decreases the chance
someone will come looking for the girls
he captures and things take off rather
fast with the two they flirt dance order
take out and yes have sex get that deep
but there are also a few red flags steve
doesn't have any social media he's
pretty much impossible to find online
and his name is steve but he wants to
surprise her with a mini vacation to a
secluded place in cottage grove oregon
what could go wrong he ends up bill
cosby her drink and it isn't until 33
minutes into the movie that we actually
get the introductory credits i actually
like this it was different and felt
right like this is where the movie
really starts noah wakes up chained in a
basement understandably freaked the [ __ ]
out but steve isn't here to have his way
with her he just wants her for her
delicious meat i'm not gonna kill you
right away
because the fresher the meat the better
yes steve is a sadistic psychopath who
captures women and sells their meat
piece by piece to affluent customers
across the globe throughout the film
we'll see as he takes multiple victims
removes pieces of their body stores them
in a meat locker cuts those pieces and
prepares vacuum sealed delicacies for
his clients they even get a goodie bag
filled with their personal effects and
photos it's a pretty lucrative business
and as noah is soon to find out she's
not the only one there in a cell beside
her is a woman named penny we're not
sure how long penny has been here but as
we'll find out later she's already had
her leg removed steve likes to take
pieces of these women in chunks keeping
them alive to preserve the freshness
next to penny is a woman we never see
except in this photo here melissa it's
likely she's been here longer than penny
she's gone mad and spends most of the
film blabbering nonsense meanwhile
molly's concern for her friend finding
out that a picture sent from noah's
phone could easily be reverse image
searched this takes her on a quest to
find out more about the mysterious man
noah has fallen for asking her bartender
friend paul for the name of the man who
took noah out to his bar a few nights
earlier she makes a shocking discovery
when it's found out steve is married
with kids back at the meat dungeon noah
asks steve if she can take a shower but
really this is a sly opportunity to
check the surroundings outside her cell
this is something we'll see her do
throughout the movie she's always
looking for ways to escape she'll scout
out the windows clock the knives and
even discover the dumbwaiter which will
be used later noah tries to escape but
is easily subdued by her captor and when
she awakes she finds out steve has
removed the first part of her body her
ass i'm not entirely sure how that works
and frankly i'm a bit too afraid to
google it as she recovers noah finds out
that none of the other girls have slept
with steve at least none that we know of
and in one of the magazines she's given
one of the former captives has left a
message if you're reading this it means
he likes you use it keep fighting we'll
later find the woman who wrote this
message as part of steve's trophy wall
where he keeps mementos of all his kills
through her friend paul molly gets the
name of the guy who went out with noah
and is able to find his wife's facebook
profile so molly does what any good
friend would do and show up at her
doorstep to expose him as a cheater
remember at this point molly doesn't
know noah's been kidnapped or that steve
is an insane cannibal but when steve or
should i say his real name brendan says
he has no idea who noah is it looks like
molly's reached a dead end that is until
she calls noah's number and steve
conveniently has her phone on him but
the big shocker here is that the wife is
in on the whole thing too and she ends
up knocking molly out and becoming one
of his captives noah starts to change
her tactics in order to get on steve's
good side she takes interest in steve's
profession when he started how he
prepares the meals this newfound
interest spurs steve to take her on a
romantic dinner complete with human
meatball a meal which she'll throw up as
soon as she gets back to her cell a meal
which steve said would normally cost 30
thousand dollars we also get more
insight into his character he started
eating human flesh at the age of 19 and
couldn't stop thinking about it he liked
how it made him feel and soon found a
small community of people who felt the
same way he did for steve there's
nothing more beautiful in the world than
someone surrendering themselves to
another giving yourself over to become
one with another noah finds that this
tactic pays off and soon steve has
invited her to a special dinner and even
gets her a pink dress of course it's
pink in a movie about flesh this is a
full course meal including liver pate
and breast we know the liver comes from
melissa the other captive woman who went
crazy but it's hinted that the breast is
actually molly's the night before steve
performs surgery on her he tells noah
that it might quote taste familiar and
there are a few moments we see molly
clutch her chest in pain you saved the
breast till last but it's not all fun
and games for noah she's here to
manipulate steve in order to survive
breaking down and telling him that she
feels awful because eating another
person doesn't make her feel awful she
should be feeling bad but she doesn't
it's a sly tactic to make steve
empathize with her and it works
you're just different
and i knew it from the moment i met you
this compliments his line earlier in
which he says you know how i knew you
were special
because you're [ __ ] up too at the end
of the dinner when they've had such a
great time he tells her he forgot to
handcuff her and she says she forgot too
this is yet another way she's
telegraphing her trust to him that she's
so into him she forgot she was captive
this allows him to open up to her and
show her his trophy case of past victims
and when she asks where her stuff is he
tells her he keeps it to himself for
steve noah is special she's not like the
other girls and that's exactly the angle
noah is trying to exploit when the two
get intimate and you could see this
moment coming a mile away she bites his
dick off that's got to hurt i don't care
where you're from but noah's first
instinct isn't to run the hell out of
there it's to save the other women and
no one knows there's another way of
escape remember how i said she was great
at observing things she knows there's a
dumb waiter they can use to get upstairs
now steve having his dick bitten off
isn't all too pleased so a raw rumble
ensues in the kitchen with steve getting
his head bashed in with a meat mallet
allowing the girls to escape into the
forest now i just gotta mention there's
this whole other side story where paul
uses gps to track molly's phone but when
he gets to the location and hears
gunshots he runs away and we never see
him again at first i was like what was
the point of this but i think it's just
the writer's way of saying fu to the
cliche of the man coming in to save the
day but i digress meanwhile anne whose
husband hasn't been picking up her calls
makes her way to the cottage and finds
the candlelit dinner and blood
everywhere she even finds her husband's
wedding ring in the bedroom along with a
collection of personal effects belonging
to both him and noah including noah's
driver's license this is how she'll
identify noah as being the woman her
husband has been cheating with steve
pursues noah but the women tag team him
holding him at gunpoint on the ground
and noah asks him to smile something she
was told to do by him throughout the
movie now you think the movie would be
over but when noah goes off on her own
to find her phone she's confronted by
anne posing as another one of steve's
captives remember noah doesn't know anne
is steve's wife enraged knowing noah was
the woman who her husband was cheating
with she tries to kill her but it's
molly who comes in and saves the day the
movie ends with noah's phone receiving a
text message from that guy from the
beginning of the movie asking you up
it's a fun little sting but i couldn't
stop thinking about anne i actually
found her the most intriguing character
in the film in one of the weirdest
scenes she pulls back this skin on her
face as if seeing what she'd look like
with a facelift steve is a plastic
surgeon and will later inspect her face
but it's just really weird we then see
her reveal her prosthetic leg there's no
real point in the story for her having a
fake leg the actress certainly doesn't
have one and it just costs more money
for the vfx department to remove it so
why what if anne was a former captive of
steve's steve has been eating human
flesh since he was 19. what if he fell
in love with her just like he did with
noah and sammy we also see that steve is
able to cut off legs just like he did
with penny what if he did the same to
anne but during his love affair with her
got her pregnant and through some [ __ ]
up stockholm syndrome the two built a
life together working together as a team
we saw how when noah showed interest in
his cannibalistic tendencies how he
beamed and wanted to bring her into his
world is it too far-fetched in an
already far-fetched movie to think
there's some truth to this or did i miss
something entirely and i'm way off base
i want to hear your thoughts and
theories in the comments below thanks
for watching everyone make sure to like
and subscribe and for more bad takes you
can follow me on twitter and instagram
at thinkstoryyt until next time remember
get that date
you